bienvenue à paris à l'automne si c'est
mélissa mollen depuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question de hugo qui me demande
est ce que les innu sont une société
matriarcale où patriarcal égaux c'est
une bonne question parce que c'est
difficile de pouvoir expliquer avec des
mots qui ne représente pas vraiment
culturellement c'est que notre culture
est souvent j'aurais préféré plutôt que
de dire patriarcale et matriarcat 16h30
par la mère ou le père
on ne s'est pas très linéaire ou
matrilinéaire est souvent la partie qui
va diriger le clan ou le groupe recevant
être la responsabilité de ceux qui vont
être les premiers à soient chassés ou à
faire pousser le maïs la courge des
haricots comme on voit chez et les modes
donc chez les i nous comme une société
chasseurs cueilleurs
on va voir beaucoup plus patrilinéaire
parce que c'est le chasseur qui va faire
la grosse chasse donc on va suivre le
chasseur c'est lui qui veut trouver la
viande et l'animal sacrifié le caribou
qui va nous permettre justement d'aller
vers une survie beaucoup plus certaine
cependant on va vraiment voir aussi
l'apport des femmes dans la petite
chasse de la chasse qui va se faire
autour du campement l'appel jeu si on va
toujours poser des filets en attendant
que les hommes reviennent avec des gros
gibiers les femmes vont faire de la
chasse de petit gibier donc tu peux
vraiment qu'on peut pas parler d'un
pouvoir supérieur sur l'un ou l'autre il
y avait une codépendance des hommes et
des femmes à tous les niveaux comme les
les femmes du système matrilinéaire
allait dépendre si des hommes
mais les hommes à dépendre aussi des
femmes donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
parler d'un pouvoir de dominance sur un
gros coup sur l'autre mais je dois
avouer que c'est souvent très incompris
quand on parle même de féminisme
autochtone de voir à quel point cette
lutte de pouvoir entre les hommes et les
femmes n'étaient vraiment pas
culturellement à la base des communautés
autochtones donc chez les i nous on
n'est pas très linéaire mais je peux te
dire que la grand mère a toujours le
dernier mot
et ça c'est ça a été prouvé
scientifiquement donc j'espère que ça
n'a pu répondre à ta question hugo
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions n'hésitez pas à partager les
vidéos bonne semaine